[Applaudissements
] c'est parti
un plateau et une lumière Vova care en Amérique
tout le monde est un critique qui regarde critiquer
enterica tout le monde vous regarde les
gens dans le sandwich tout le monde ma
chérie personne n'essaie de partager mais vous êtes tous des
leaders sur Paris et je pense qu'ils
besoin de carottes dites-moi pourquoi ils
jouent avec les cinq et une garnison des
enfants sur le percocet trébuchant sur le
médicament appelez-le comme je le vois nous nous
droguons les Américains tout le monde suit
un délice dirige les gens adore ça
transformer les enfants à la saison  ils
disent que la raison est de protéger la liberté
quand nous ne les croyons pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout ce dont nous avons besoin
c'est juste de nous tu n'as pas deviné que la guerre
est la réponse mais vraiment quelle est la
question quand tu as un cadeau ici tu as
des os offensifs tu as sa connexion pour
survivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
nous sho  tu choisirais l'amour au lieu d'une grosse
bougie téméraire dans l'obscurité il
changera le sans-cœur son amour pour te guider a
copié chaque liste de garde l'as-tu
regardé gobo nous sommes comme dans une chaloupe les
enfants remontent la rivière pour la promener livrer
précieux aux masses
peu importe votre statut, rien n'est jamais
fini nous croyons aux secondes chances des
bébés meurent comme des poissons en caoutchouc
vivants deux fois pour les droits qu'ils ont s'il vous plaît
plus de violence
dites-nous maintenant nous essayons ensemble nous sommes
unis quand nous sommes un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]